cette vidéo appelle ce parmi vous qui
utilisez l'extension tournesol à remplir
le formulaire en description pour nous
permettre d'analyser l'impact des
recommandations tournesol dans le cadre
d'une recherche scientifique en
partenariat avec le laboratoire de
sciences des données de l'école pretting
fédérale de Lausanne au nom de toute
l'équipe de tournesol et des chercheurs
de l'EPFL je vous remercie profondément
d'avance ce parmi vous qui participerez
à cette étude plus de détails en fin de
vidéo
jusque là la recherche scientifique sur
l'impact psychologique et social des
réseaux sociaux et des algorithmes de
recommandation et souvent restreinte à
l'étude de ceux qui ne va pas comme les
tours-rommentaux les suicides le
harcèlement les billets sexistes et
racistes les appels à la haine la
désinformation l'industrie du doute la
propagation des rumeurs et provocations
les arnaques les appels à la violence
physique voire les appels au génocide il
faut dire que c'est plus facile
d'étudier ce qui existe et
malheureusement comme le révèle si bien
les Facebook files ce qui existe
aujourd'hui sur le web ce sont avant
tout des réseaux sociaux et des
algorithmes de recommandation conçus par
des entreprises privées attirées par le
profit soumis à l'influence malsaine de
gouvernements ou de partis politiques
parfois autoritaires et manipuler à
longueur de journée par des campagnes de
désinformation et de manipulation
idéologiques à l'instar notamment de ce
qui s'est passé autour de Cambridge
anatica sauf que à l'instar du
changement climatique exposé et
expliquer les problèmes de suffira pas à
éviter un désastre il faut aussi et
surtout proposer des solutions pour
atténuer drastiquement les risques et
ainsi éviter les pires scénarios comme
vous le savez sans doute c'est
exactement ce qu'on cherche faire avec
tournesol mais proposer des idées de
solution ce n'est pas suffisant beaucoup
d'idées de solutions pour lutter contre
le changement climatique comme par
exemple supprimer ces emails sont en
fait de fausses bonnes idées notamment
parce que l'impact de ces interventions
est minime voire contre-productif à
cause de l'effet de rebond bref pour
vraiment combattre les crises
informationnelle et l'amplification de
la haine il faut constamment évaluer les
idées de solution et si possible il faut
le faire avec autant de rigueur
scientifiques que possible et bien
tournesol s'inscrit naturellement dans
cette démarche en particulier nous avons
initier un partenariat avec Robert West
Emmanuel Ribeiro respectivement
professeur et doctorant du Laboratoire
de sciences de données de l'école
polyteinée fédérale de Lausanne est déjà
auteur par ailleurs de plusieurs
analyses de fantastiques serait
sociologie des réseaux sociaux le
partenariat vise à étudier l'impact des
recommandations tournesol sur les
utilisateurs de l'extension tournesol
pour Chrome et Firefox d'ailleurs si
vous les avez pas installés je vous
invite à les installer maintenant et
pour mener cette étude à bien et bien on
va compter sur ce parmi vous qui
utilisaient déjà cette extension
tournesol
comme vous le savez peut-être pour les
académiques qui cherchent à comprendre
les réseaux sociaux le nerf de la guerre
et l'accès à des données et
malheureusement en pratique le rgpd et
ses variantes dans différents pays ces
régulations vont souvent davantage
freiner voire bloquer les recherches des
académiques et pas celles des
entreprises privées comme Google et
Facebook ou open ce qui fait alors
qu'ils auront encore plus le monopole
des réseaux sociaux sans contre-pouvoir
bref si on veut surveiller Google et
Facebook il va falloir trouver des
manières légales et bien sûr éthiques
d'accéder à des données intéressantes et
à l'instar de Mozilla et de son étude
sur les recommandations YouTube nous
misons sur votre bienveillance et votre
consentement pour nous permettre
d'étudier l'historique de votre
utilisation de YouTube en particulier ce
qui va le plus nous intéresser c'est
d'essayer de déterminer un changement de
consommation informatique suite à
l'installation de l'extension tournesol
cette installation vous a-t-elle conduit
à consommer davantage d'informations de
qualité à vous tenir davantage informés
sur des sujets de grande importance à
moins consommer des informations de
moindre qualité pour répondre
rigoureusement à ces questions il nous
faut avoir accès à des historiques de
consommation YouTube et c'est possible
d'utilisateurs qui n'utilisaient pas à
l'extension tournesol donc ça c'est
facile à trouver et qui se sont mis à
l'utiliser à un moment donné et c'est
pour cela que nous demandons aux bonnes
âmes parmi vous si vous le souhaitez
bien sûr de télécharger l'historique de
votre consommation YouTube et de
partager cette historique avec
l'association tournesol pour y arriver
il vous suffit de suivre les
instructions du formulaire dont le lien
est en description ces données seront
alors sous la responsabilité de
l'association et à ne seront partagées
qu'avec des chercheurs du Laboratoire de
sciences de données de l'EPFL afin
qu'ils puissent en faire l'analyse ces
données seront ensuite supprimées une
fois l'analyse effectuée ne seront
ensuite rendus publics que des
statistiques agrégées dans la
publications scientifique que nous
rédigerons après avoir pris le soin bien
sûr de bien vérifier que les risques
pour la protection des données
personnelles seront minimes j'espère que
vous ferez confiance en notre
professionnalisme et notre éthique en
acceptant de participer à notre
expérience les formulaires à remplir
contiennent par ailleurs d'autres
questions certaines questions étant en
socio-démographie pour comprendre la
population étudiée et d'autres
déclaratives pour collecter votre
ressenti vis-à-vis de votre utilisation
de l'extension tournesol et alors bien
sûr restera bien sûr d'énormes biais
dans l'analyse ainsi effectuée en
premier lieu chers spectateurs vous
n'êtes clairement pas représentatif de
la population générale vous êtes même
beaucoup plus cool que la population
générale puisque regardez ça ne folle et
donc tout résultat de cette analyse ne
correspondra pas vraiment à ce qui se
passerait si les algorithmes de
recommandation de YouTube étaient
soudainement conduit robustement
bénéfique en promouvant des contenus
jugés consensuellement désirables à
recommander massivement par une large
communauté de citoyens et
potentiellement d’experts par ailleurs
l’étude qu'on va faire est uniquement
observationnelle bon après faire une
expérience en double aveugle grandeur
nature c'est comme vous l'imaginez
complètement illusoire néanmoins nous
sommes persuadés que les résultats
seront déjà très intéressants et
permettront au moins de déterminer si
l'extension de tournesol modifie et en
particulier améliore les habitudes de
consommation de la sous population qui
en a entendu parler et qui a choisi de
l'installer
si bien entendu la question scientifique
est au cœur de cette étude ses objectifs
vont bien au-delà de la simple question
scientifique comme j'en ai déjà beaucoup
parlé dans cette série de vidéos la
recherche académique publique est
aujourd'hui obsédée par des sujets qui à
mes yeux semblent beaucoup moins
prioritaires que la maîtrise
collaborative de l'information la plus
propagée sur le web voir beaucoup des
études scientifiques à l'heure actuelle
sont en fait extrêmement dangereuses
comme l'optimisation d'algorithmes déjà
hors de contrôle démocratique et qui
menacent déjà clairement la sécurité des
démocraties qui plus est des algorithmes
dont on sait pertinemment qui ne sont
absolument pas sécurisés ainsi un
objectif de cette recherche est aussi à
mes yeux d'attirer l'attention des
académiques sur des urgences sociétales
et sur le rôle critique que ces
académiques doivent jouer pour atténuer
ses risques à l'instar de ce qui se
passe pour les chercheurs du climat
notamment car leur expertise rare est
souvent indispensable pour bien
comprendre les enjeux et pour proposer
des solutions de la même manière nous
espérons attirer l'attention des
étudiants des journalistes et des
politiques sur l'importance de
promouvoir l'information de qualité sur
les réseaux sociaux et sur les solutions
pour faire cela de manière col décoratif
et sécurisé et là encore chacun d'entre
vous peut grandement nous aider dans
cette tâche vous pouvez ainsi vous
informer davantage sur l'importance du
projet par exemple à travers l'excellent
livre algocratie d'Arthur grimmompon
avec la fantastique chaîne Youtube la
fabrique sociale de Victor ou encore en
suivant le génial Jean-Loup Fourquet
alias après la bière sur Twitter ou
Youtube pour ensuite pouvoir expliquer
ces enjeux à vos proches et bien sûr
vous pouvez aussi avoir un rôle plus
actif en partageant les contenus de
qualité produit par ces personnes et par
d'autres et en promouvant tournesol sur
les réseaux sociaux et dans votre
entourage sociaux professionnel surtout
si vous travaillez dans le monde de la
tech ou dans le monde académique enfin
vous pouvez aider le tournesol plus
directement encore en effectuant un don
à l'association tournesol qui nous
aidera à payer le salaire de notre
excellent développeur en comparant les
vidéos YouTube pour identifier les
vidéos d'intérêts publics sur tournesol
ainsi déterminer quelle vidéo
l'extension recommandera en contribuant
à notre base de code Open Source en
licence libre accessible sur GitHub en
venant sur notre discorde pour interagir
avec notre communauté et répondre aux
questions qu'elle se posent ou encore en
vous impliquant dans l'association
tournesol par exemple en nous aidant à
écrire des demandes de subvention plus
que jamais à travers le monde le chaos
informationnel menace les démocraties
surtout sur Internet j'espère que je
peux compter sur vous pour nous aider à
combattre ce chaos et à introduire des
structures innovantes pour le faire de
manière démocratique et sécurisée toute
l'équipe de tournesol et tous les
collaborateurs de cette équipe vous en
remercie profondément d'avance